[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute möchte ich jedoch was herzhaftes
backen deswegen gibt es bei uns heute
pizza donuts ein fingerfood was
hoffentlich später ganz gut aussieht die
basis ist die baustelle da draußen die
nervt mich total aber das ist nicht
schlimm ignorierten lärm einfach ich
singe einfach weg die basis ist ein
hefeteig den ich eigentlich immer für
pizza zubereiten
ja die basis solcher vertrag den ich
immer für das war ein sehr falscher satz
die basis ist ein hefeteig den ich für
meine pizza präferiere auch das klingt
doch gut dafür verwende ich einen halben
würfel hefe einem teelöffel zucker 250
milliliter oder gramm wasser es ist
lauwarm 450 km je einen teelöffel salz
und 45 gramm olivenöl das ist mein
zauber stark mit diesem werde ich jetzt
die hefe mit dem wasser und dem zucker
verrühren und wenn nein lass ich damit
medizin fersen ist sitzt medizin
es ist grünen bändern laufen von zucker
mit qualität besitzt dann schmeckt sie
gleich genauso gut nein irgendwie war
der text anders egal
und jetzt wird dieses hilfe gemisch wie
durch zauberei aufgehen das heißt ihr
lasst das jetzt wenn ihr möchtet einfach
15 minuten bei raumtemperatur stehen wie
es ist blubbert und seht ihr auch ob die
hefe wirklich schön funktionieren ihr
könnt sie aber auch direkt
weiterverarbeiten
aber das vor aufgehen bewirkt dass der
hefeteig auch gleich schnell auf geht
und ich mache das jetzt so ich geh zum
backofen und 13 w durch zauberei hab ich
hier mein hierfür wasser mit super
bläschen
das kommt jetzt hier direkt alles in
meiner rührschüssel mit dem komplett
mehl hefe wasser dann wird das jetzt
hier verrückt
und ganz zum schluss geht das salz und
das öl hinzu denn so kann die bewunderer
auf ich bin gespannt wie lange ich meine
man kopien zustimmen
denkt diesem video beibehalten werde
aber ich bin gerade in der provinz
stimmung gibt knetet ihr den teig für
etwa zehn minuten ist so schön
geschmeidig ist es gibt bei mir
natürlich viel schneller fertig jetzt
ist ein super geschmeidiger pizzateig
entstanden und ich wette die schlüssel
einfach mit dem crystal und lassen den
teig auf gehen entweder eine stunde
abgedeckt bei raumtemperatur oder eine
halbe stunde bei der stufe im dampf
backofen und dann kann ich eigentlich
schon mal dicke luft verbreiten bzw den
belag für den belag brauche ich
tomatenmark das sind 150 gramm 50 gramm
wasser etwas knoblauch ich verwende noch
so druck ich habe ich noch etwas café
keese oregano salz und pfeffer also mehr
braucht man hier wirklich nicht und das
geht super super einfach ich nehme das
tomatenmark und weil es einfach sehr
stark konzentriert ist gebe ich das
wasser dazu eine knoblauch knolle
nein eine knoblauchzehe und ihr könnt
die pizza donuts jetzt wirklich auch
belegen wie ihr möchtet
ich hab da so was im korb deswegen
probier's mal aus guck mal wenn ihr eine
knoblauchpresse benutzt müsst ihr den
knoblauch schälen
denn er wird durch gedrückt und ist
bleibt einfach die haut zurück die
schale haut klingt ein bisschen eklig
die schale bleibt zurück dann mit salz
und pfeffer würzen
es sieht immer noch so nach viel aus
aber es ist ja nicht so viele oregano
mit rein hoch
ernsthaft kurz zur seite und beim käse
nehmen die jetzt einen der einfach
wunderbar schmidt entweder café keese
verschmilzt echt extrem gut und schmeckt
gut oder einen gau da zum beispiel jetzt
einfach grob reiben
[Musik]
da muss ich echt sagen bin ich der
totale verfechter von geriebenem käse in
tüten york schaffte geriebenen käse in
tüten zu hause
denn ganz ehrlich so käser am stück ist
zum einen günstiger zum anderen hält
länger und man spart sich einfach die
trennmittel in der tüte und deswegen
gibt es bei uns keinen geriebenen käse
sondern wir haben ihn einfach und ihr
könnt ja auch einfach so käser am stück
auch in größeren mengen kaufen können
den reiben und auch einfrieren und habe
dann immer was auf vorrat
aber ich finde zum käse ist wirklich
schnell gerieben und da sparen wir uns
zum einen die mehr verpackungen die
leute entsteht und die trennmittel im
käse also eigentlich habe ich jetzt
alles vorbereitet guckt mal so söbbeler
was hat echt mega perfekt wäre die pizza
donuts werden wenn ihr kleine und
salamis habt ihr so ganz klein sind so
dünne ich glaube ich steche so ein paar
aus einfach nur der optik areva oder ihr
könnt sie auch schneiden dann sind
kleine dreiecke sind auch nicht schlecht
ausgesehen mini-pc stückchen zum in
ibiza stützen
ich glaube das machen wir denn das wort
sagt sich wenn sie das jetzt aussticht
was macht er dann im recht
[Musik]
da ja so mini 3 gibt es jedoch süß aus
mini pizza stückchen auf donath pizza
döner pizza donuts
[Musik]
ich mach pizza donnersdorf pizza tonno
entschuldigung ist hier einst aktiv
unterwegs
[Gelächter]
ich habe hier noch möchtest du
franken
mein papa würde sagen kinos also dessen
tochter ist das sieht aus wie käse jetzt
geht's deiner freundin wieder rüber eine
scheinehe dann immer noch eine scheibe
für deine freundin mit kleiner
schmetterling oder filet oder 11 was ach
du bist eine verlegung stimmt schließt
für die tür bitte jetzt geht's direkt am
haus rollen und zwar nennt ihr ein wenig
mehr an eurem teig da jetzt auch so
wunderbar aufgegangen sein sollte
und jetzt auf 1 cm stärke ausrollen ich
mach das jetzt hier mit diesen abstand
bringen ich hab dich einfach drauf
geklemmt und rein geschraubt oder ihr
versucht es eben einfach so gleichmäßig
auszurollen
ich glaube ich nimmt doch acht
millimeter denn die lasse ich jetzt noch
gut luftig aufgehen
kommando zurück 15 dieser nicht nicht zu
dünn werden
8 mm
[Musik]
jetzt werden die donuts ausgesprochen
ich nehme jetzt hier zwei ausstecher
einer hat 9 cm andere viereinhalb im
durchmesser und jetzt kann ich hier
schön alles ausstechen
[Musik]
denn das loch in der mitte ausstechen
und das sieht jetzt so ziemlich dünn aus
aber da geht ja gleich noch auf das
heißt ich setzte es hier direkt auf ein
blech mit viel abstand und den
restlichen teig knetet noch mal zusammen
lassen kurz ruhen bis ich die dann hier
gestrichen habe und da kann ich dann
auch nochmal ausrollen und eben auch
nochmal so verarbeiten
so hat das reich austrocknet jetzt
streiche ich hier das tomatenmark drauf
also die pizza soße ganz vorsichtig und
die sup stücke und auch den käse strich
aber dann erst später drauf denn ich
lasse jetzt erstmal ordentlich noch
einmal aufgehen dann habe ich ja auch
mehr fläche die ich belegen kann
und dann fällt jetzt auch erstmal nichts
runter
[Musik]
zwei bleche gehen jetzt gerade schon auf
hier habe ich noch die restlichen vier
den tag habe ich jetzt noch übrig und
jetzt guck mal da mache ich jetzt
einfach so damit wirklich der komplett
aufgebraucht wird
ich freue mich ihn zu einem strang legt
den so rum und verbindet das so groß war
wie in der regel produktion war ich
mach's nochmal mitverfolgen
also einmal so zu machen die auch das
hab ich dann rum regen und dann einfach
so
und dann haben wir bis zum schluss den
kompletten teig fertig ich bestreite
jetzt noch ganz kurz die anderen sind
echt schon gut aufgegangen
und damit geht es dann gleich weiter mit
dem belegen
ich glaube so ein bisschen tomatensoße
verteile ich noch drüber
also wenn ihr seht es wird ein bisschen
zu wenig gibt noch was drauf ich muss
sagen ich mag auch diese schildkröten
optik dass es oben wie so ein
schildkrötenpanzer aussieht durch die
risse
das ist gerade eigentlich dieses zu
bereiten ist gerade so eine folter weil
sie drin so lecker riecht
eben war schon ein baby und marcel da
und haben auch schon so was gibt es denn
hier
[Musik]
hier belegte ich jetzt gerade die pizza
döner magic und käse und dann kommen sie
direkt in den vorgeheizten backofen
ich backe jetzt bei ober unterhitze ich
sie halt gar sind
da ich sehe noch nicht gemacht habe weiß
ich nicht wann sie gar sind aber ich
schreibe euch dann rein
sobald ich einen erfahrungswert habe oh
mann ich will endlich dass die backen
und dann wie sie essen können
[Musik]
so sehen die pizza donuts aus ich muss
sagen ich glaube ich probiere es beim
nächsten mal mit der pizza stufe dann
doch denn sie sind mir teilweise doch
ein bisschen zu hell
also es ist ein super durch gebacken und
auch unten schön hellbraun aber ich
glaube pizza stufe wäre vielleicht sogar
besser ich probiere es nächstes mal aus
ich glaube das war jetzt nicht das
letzte mal dass ich sie zubereitet habe
und jetzt darf probieren
noch steht normalerweise hinter der
kamera aber kaum hitze aussagen
dieses entsteht ist es schon fast das
schönste richtig cool
das wird doch ich die schönen von
überrascht wie gut ich glaube ich finde
von dem also bei dem die reform sogar am
schönsten und besaß aber fairerweise
muss man sagen es hat die richtige
tonart form erreicht na ja schön pizza
kringe ja komm wir probieren
ich bin gespannt was mit den kleinen
home style nach jakobs mich vor der
kamera probieren
aber ich glaube dass die anderen
lockerer sind als derweil der weise das
endstück bestimmt aber ich muss sagen
ich mag pizza liefern sie ein bisschen
größer ist
geschmacklich echt cool ich meine
normale pizza kann auch aus der hand
essen aber braucht halt immer so die
zweite hand für innen und wie sollte
alles herunter beziehung doch man
verbrennt sich das zahnfleisch finden
und behinderten schneidezähne thomas
mack also ich finde sie echt cool dass
auch so ein kraut wieder los und somit
partie definitiv ein kraut witterung zum
zu greifen einfach hinstellen und jeder
kann zu kaufen also ich glaube man
könnte tatsächlich noch einen ticken
doch kleiner machen ich hatte angst ich
wusste nicht so genau wie weit geht der
teig auf aber man kann sich da
eigentlich an meinem normalen donuts
video ein bisserl orientieren
ich wusste nur nicht so eigentlich sah
genauso gut machen können
egal das hat ein test und ihr könnt sehr
einfach anders machen
ich bin jedenfalls ziemlich cool bronze
gern aus und ich finde ich schon schon
ein gutes rezept also nötig bis zum
nächsten mal
ich bin übrigens auch auf tik tok jetzt
ja ich habe es ausprobiert
ich hab jetzt schon die ersten paar
videos gemacht zuerst habe ich nicht
ganz verstanden das tik tok ist aber ich
glaube so langsam so langsam wird meine
kleine samma die große die ist meine
lehrerin tätig doch geht
[Musik]